do you guys know why I brought you into
the nether no no - give us diamonds well
here's the deal boys you guys have one
hour and whoever has the most nether
right when this countdown hits zero wins
$10,000 Oh
oh yeah whoever has the least has to
kiss Chris's saw oh yeah
if Chris loses then he has to kiss Karl
saw ogress yeah what are you doing this
59 minutes left
you tricked me I'm very slow I've
already got another gold mine in it hey
Chris hey bud Oh Oh easy now that's not
very nice don't find some nether right
I'm getting nether gold you need gold
I'm actually pretty epic I'm mining what
if I just go ahead and end this video
real quick huh what did you get ancient
debris shut up I'm just kidding I was
actually really excited for you and
happy for you whoa oh hey also Chris if
you kill me alright there's a creeper oh
man hey Chandler hey yo back up every
time there's creepers chill it just eat
them hey Jimmy hold on hold on watch
this oh yes Chandler whatever dude I'm
literally gonna die
ancient debris every time you see debris
it makes me think of Capri Sun debris
Sun can you sleep in that bed for me oh
he's getting you to mind for him you
cheater
you guys know what why you have to be at
right what no you didn't know that no
I've just been mighty regular I'm
actually pretty epic Oh watch out
I was over here trying to find my why
hey Carl there's more I'm pretty epic
don't fall oh my gosh Carl is surrounded
by like seven creepers brah I'm
confusion am I supposed to get down to
the Y I'm supposed to get down if
there's lava there my thing is I didn't
know you had to get down to a specific Y
what oh oh my god oh my god please hey
you did not get it ancient debris did
you it's called ancients trap whenever
you dig it but yeah I got it all
you guys can't sabotage I don't even hey
you and Chandler near each other if you
want to do get out
Oh Lala huh you guys gonna fight no not
until I find something stop dude
frickin he's rad yeah come over here I
have officially reached the why I
reached the why it was very hard and
there's a lot of dangerous things around
me you reached low why Carl how do you
feel yeah after you killed Chandler um I
actually feel bad I thought he was
trying to kill me
cuz he said he wanted to kill me uh-huh
save my life Blackstone hey Jimmy look
at me in the eyes man do I look like I'm
kidding when I say I'm gonna win this
one kinda also don't forget whoever
comes the last has to kiss us ah I'm
more worried about that than worried
about not winning $10,000 for some
reason girl you should just be worried
in general because until you win you
don't get a facecam will never see how
anguished your face was right then I'm
like dream except better at Minecraft
hey Chris are you excited to kiss Carl
sock I'm not gonna have to kiss car luck
at all and I feel like I'm close that
sounds like the cry of somebody that's
about to kiss a sock oh that sounds like
somebody's gonna kiss a sock there Carl
want to say that you guys have 40
minutes left until someone kisses a sock
what if nobody wins and you all just
sucks wait what is this what is this
well you look like ancient debris
anymore no uh-oh
oh my gosh oh yes I've been mining these
tunnels for quite a minute Jimmy Carl
that's right now you won't get a facecam
you know I'm getting tired about winning
I really am this is where I'm at imagine
how I feel Carl yeah we will know
exactly when he finds it cuz it'll just
be the sound like that feel like I'm
getting closer
Oh watch out Chandler watch out Chandler
turn around as if this wasn't hard
enough Jimmy's over here trying to kill
us and I mean we want to just I want to
mine that way well I see you I see you I
see you it's got all the ones on the map
apparently I don't get it I've blown
everything up me and Chris muted our
Mike Chandler doesn't realize this but
he literally walked past it are you
dying see if he gets a vein of three
Carl would be the person to kill me and
then take my spot in fine stuff
Carl is so lucky he really is call is
the luckiest person I've only Chandler
had luck maybe his luck will turn around
what are you guys doing walk fast at
like five times
did you guys spawn it there no but he is
using beds to mine out large areas why
Taylor why didn't you split the wool we
didn't know there was wool to be had Hey
he's cheating it I only got one dude
what the heck I wish bets could stack
that would be a bunkbed wouldn't i Carl
want to see your first bet explosions I
really hope he knows how to do it I do
not he's gonna kill himself wait stop
being SpaghettiOs I want to know how to
do it talking in a cute voice when I get
you insider info brah oh shoot I'm dead
I'm gonna sneak in watches christos that
way
I can do it I need to just get back to
where my stuff plus there's a llama
everywhere now I think you hit like it's
Chris can you mute your mic for me real
quick how do you blow off a bit all
right so what you do is you take the bed
you put it down
look you just put a block in front of it
I was trying to trick you into showing
Karl and you just killed yourself wait
is this it
let's freakin go I found one freak Oh
baby another one oh my god how did I die
I put it over the freaking bed where do
you put the block you I'm in a teepee
you here Karl to random tunnel wait do I
lose all my stuff because of that like
my ancient debris no you don't get it
back I'm gonna give you your armor and
tools back I wish I could just find
where my original spot was I got me one
oh there's an intimate I don't know
where I am
I spawned where you told me to spawn and
now I'm gonna die alright so the biggest
thing is I got to get back to negative
30 which is this way but there's an
entire thing a lava so I don't know if I
need to go up some first or down some
first but I'm worried I'm gonna hit lava
Chris I'm worried you're gonna have to
kiss a sock I kind of made myself have
to be a sock kisser even more
importantly than you kissing a sock if
you don't step it up Carl gets a face
cam Oh gross yeah I mean Carl's not
gonna win what the whole oh I forgot no
no why am i trapped in lava no please
haha Carl big talk for somebody who
can't even find ancient debris you idiot
I found it already in vain' also tied
look at both of us we're killing it ha
okay Jimmy I know what to do but I need
your help I need to retrace my steps
I'm gonna drop you all your stuff for
you sorry you go ahead and do that and
I'll go ahead and dig up this ancient
debris if that's good with you Jimmy all
right I don't think I ever find any more
you just gonna quit
I mean I do I need to keep going they're
clearly bad come on come on come on come
on come on
whoa I found it hey yes I found it I
found that I found that it counts it's
going in my inventory Carl what are you
gonna do about this I'm gonna win that's
what I'm gonna do Jimmy isn't it funny
that Chandler's in first place but when
he first found the thing he didn't even
notice if only somebody hadn't have told
him guys there is five minutes remaining
Carl how are you doing I'm great you
know what I'm fantastic you know why
because I'm about to find the first
eight stack anybody ever has another
right and I'm gonna win
oh sure oh cool hey if you're gonna blow
up a bed-warmer first so I can not lose
my spot I blew up a bunch for you
hopefully you find some don't think I
will see in this house it's all filled
with lava thank you though
all right that's good help Carl yes
great plan all right Carl I gave Chris
ten explosions I'm giving you ten
explosions just keep moving forward and
exploding all right Carl one explosion
two explosions oh yeah you're right I
didn't find any there's three minutes
left by the way so Chris how much dad
the right do you have I have three
nether rights crap do you have zero
nether yeah Carl how much nether I do
you have I have three ancient debris did
you have zero as well Chandler how much
dad the right do you have one ingot guys
you have two minutes left
all right well I just want like you beat
me maybe not one but definitely didn't
get last oh yeah it was a three vein oh
I'm gonna cry
wait so call here in last place now wait
stop shut up a minute and a half
remaining wait to meet Lester cool I
think you'll need to five beds oh okay
it was your bad but it's cool I'm gonna
lose
Renta all right there you go that's your
problem Oh Chris have you made it I have
to get back to my chest
25 seconds first you money we gotta make
it dude I only have to smell one of them
bra if I didn't die from the exploding
pet I would have won dad I made a
labyrinth it slum literally going in
circles at least I don't get last two
what too late Carl too late no wait I
didn't need to find the chest I brought
it all with me
the thing is whoever has the most nether
right one how much nether I do have
Chris Zira Chandler how much do you have
one Carl how much do you have zero okay
which means you and Chris must duel to
the death then Taylor before they do it
for last place you just won $10,000
let's go my first win ways that your
first win on the gaming channel yeah so
what are you gonna spend this ten grand
on I'm thinking about buying a house
okay
all right whoever loses this duel has to
kiss the other person suck duel oh oh oh
go go it what are you doing you know
that fighting off bucket of lava doesn't
seem very fair you didn't even hit the
bucket lava
I got pushed in the lava those fair
alright so Carl take your shoe off 4:14
yeah there we go thank you for watching
Congrats on your 10 grand to Matt's
amusing